but this is how and this is why you need
a reverse proxy in your life hey
everyone welcome back and in this video
i want to talk a little bit about
proxies and reverse proxies and
especially even with reverse proxies
we'll just go a little bit into nginx
because i have worked a lot with nginx
and it is a fantastic open source free
reverse proxy software available so
let's see how these work and what these
exactly are also if you're new here make
sure you leave a like subscribe to the
channel and hit the bell icon in order
to receive free daily updates on
programming on code dam this video is a
part of code dam's t-shirt giveaway
program for the month if you want to
take part and win an amazing goal damn
t-shirt all you have to do is leave a
comment on this video about what you
think and that's it you are eligible if
your comment gets a heart from code damn
you will win a t-shirt for absolutely
free okay let's say you created your own
family website
let's say this is family.com
or whatever and then
slash
i have my name
right this let's assume this page should
be rendered by a node.js app right
because node.js is my favorite
programming language let's say the
second member we have m2 for example
likes
vue.js a lot right and this is just a
static website for example this is a
obviously a server side rendered thing
because we are using node.js with let's
say some ejs as a system and then slash
member 3
likes to have php
right as their home page now you want to
create this system how would you
possibly create something like this just
think about this for a minute now if you
have watched the code damn http
fundamentals course which is a free
course on codedam.com you know a few
things about how domain names work so
you see this domain right here could
ideally at a given time only resolve to
one ip address which your browser would
connect to right so this would be a
single ip address and for the sake of
simplicity let's just assume for now
that you're hosting this on ec2 or some
standard linux virtual machine right now
the problem is that whenever your
browser whenever your browser tries to
connect to server the first step in the
connection part is that it locates that
server with the help of this ip address
which you specify and does not use this
path information or anything or even
port numbers if you specify in this
communication in the initial
communication right this path and
everything goes in the http body when
the communication is happening so that
means the option of having multiple
servers is eliminated right at least
right now so in terms of you know just
keeping the things simple if you have a
simple ip ec2 app instance you pretty
much cannot point it to different
servers on just different path names
right they have to point on a single ip
address at a given point okay so this is
where the things get interesting what we
actually wanted to do is we wanted to
say that hey my client i want if you're
on slash mehul then you want to have
this node.js which might be another
server like you were thinking this could
be another server for let's say m2 and
this could be another server for let's
say m3 right but we just showed that
this architecture is not possible so
what we do instead of this
is that we write a special program on
the server itself which does this
handling and we put client one layer
behind right so your server right here
now determines
what path you are coming in this in this
specific case right whether it's me hole
whether it's m2 whereas m3 and the
client is just connecting to a regular
server right so this
might as well be ec2 now now this is
interesting because these
can be separate ec2s and this software
which does this right here is called as
a reverse proxy it's as simple as that
reverse proxy is just a piece of
software which does this mapping in some
way which does this
direction of control in some way now
this is not specific to just path it
could be pretty much any criteria from
tcp that is layer 4
i think i think layer 4 is the
lowest you could go in
engine x to all the way to http which is
your application layer at layer seven
right so you can do this with nginx you
can do this which with haproxy as well
these are the two proxies i have used
personally and i mean i do recommend
nginx but hf proxy is also good for some
use cases but yeah i mean for nginx you
can pretty much do this redirection on
the applications whether it's node.js
whether it's php whether it's view
whatever with the help of these path
names or you can do them on the basis of
port numbers
as well right so for example you can
have a port number three three three
three for this then three three three
four and so on or you can also do it for
sub domains i mean as long as a bunch of
parts are different set of urls go to
the same host which has this nginx proxy
running you can perform this redirection
right now the point is that how does
this reverse proxy system actually works
let's look into that so in this specific
case which we are discussing what will
happen
is that your client actually hits nginx
at the very first place and the reason
it hits nginx and not your node.js or
any other process is because nginx
as a server
is listening on port 80 or port 443
which is the standard port for http or
https so when that happens now nginx is
in control right and the job for nginx
is not to do any processing not to
compute this and that which your
application does but it's just simply
redirecting stuff at least in the most
in most of the cases so what it will do
is that
you can specify let's say you have a
node.js server here which listens on
port one two three four right then you
have a php server which is listening on
one two three five then you have a
vue.js server which is of course static
so these are just static files but
there's a static server running with the
help of express or whatever and this is
on one two three six
right let's see so you see these
applications are listening on ports
which are not accessible via internet
right so these ports are not accessible
via internet that means
ideally if they were accessible you
could just write port number one two
three four and bypass nginx but that's
bad for security as well as for
i mean for getting this infrastructure
ready so what we do in fact instead is
that if i'm writing slash mayhew here
engine x allows me to write a rule that
hey if the location
is in fact mehul i want the proxy to
pass at this port number so i'll say
proxy pass localhost one two three four
right so the reason i'm writing
localhost here is because i'm assuming
that node and vue.js and php are running
on the same host as this engine x is
running but this this need not to be the
case right it could very well be in the
same intranet or you know in the same
subnet so that way this redirection
would still work right you would have to
specify a different dns name or a
hard-coded ip address but this would
still work now why is this thing
important well you can think of nginx as
the ultimate middleware to your
application where you can perform all
sorts of things in a very very very
performant way because nginx is written
in c or c plus plus i don't know but you
can see it's not your node.js thing
right so c and c plus plus are actually
very very very very performant languages
i mean closest to assembly so you can do
some real
performance good damage if you're
writing your softwares in cnc plus plus
so nginx is performant it is feature
rich that means you can do rate limiting
you can do web sockets connections you
can do i don't know like there are so
many options to do you can do load
balancing you can do a lot of stuff with
nginx right so but the core fundamental
of reverse proxies is the following that
it just sits as a front layer in most of
the cases and then distributes the
traffic to different applications or
sometimes maybe the same application
running differently just to act as a
load balancer right so for example a
standard use case of node.js app would
be to have an nginx nginx process and
then let's say four nodes node apps
right and when would you do that you
would do this on a four core system why
because a node.js is a single threaded
app therefore you have basically you're
using all the four cores of your server
now with the help of nginx load
balancing kind of right so you can
perform the same load balancing with
nginx hd proxy pretty much any other
reverse proxy application as well but
this is how and this is why you need a
reverse proxy in your life because now
all the authentication
all the rate limiting all that stuff
could be in a single place and most
importantly the tls termination as well
because
this is also computationally a bit
expensive i won't say much because now i
mean it's it's basically you know the
standard stuff but tls domination is
much faster than nginx compared to
node.js tls domination is just
converting your https traffic to http
and why you need that because your
applications need to be read plain text
information coming right they don't need
to read the garbage but yep that's
pretty much it i think we covered most
of the stuff which
needs to be
known as a back-end developer if you're
just starting with reverse proxies so
that is all for this video i hope you
understood it i hope you enjoyed it if
you did make sure you leave a like
subscribe to the channel and hit the
bell icon that is all for this one i'm
gonna see you in the next video really
soon
[Music]
[Music]
you